the state of the US economy when you
look at the aggregate numbers is good
the economy is probably weakening
somewhat in large measure because high
oil prices suck out money from people's
pocketbooks which means they can't spend
them on other things the other is that
the housing market Brickley the so
called subprime housing market has
deteriorated home values have stopped
going up in some cases are going down
that puts an enormous amount of stress
on a certain group of consumers but in
aggregate the economy looks pretty good
the problem is that for many Americans
the economy and the outlook are very
uncertain for instance if you're
operating you've got two or three kids
and you're uncertain about your job your
concern your job might be outsourced
that's a obviously a source of
considerable concern education costs are
going up if you want to send your kids
to college that's a major concern oil
prices gasoline prices are going up
which as I say takes money out of your
pocket book out of your wallet means
it's less money to spend on other things
there is a concern among many people
that they'll lose their health insurance
their company will stop providing it or
when they retire they won't have
sufficient health insurance people are
concerned about Social Security whether
it's going to be there 10 or 15 years
from now and there's a real risk that as
people age in this society they simply
will not have the resources to live a
decent a decent living standard and the
other is that they're concerned that
their children will be saddled with
large amounts of government debt they'll
be saddled with prospect of higher taxes
to pay for Social Security and Medicare
they'll be saddled with increased
national dependence on foreign oil that
all these things may mean that the
coming generation may not have the same
living standards or the same
opportunities as as the past generations
in particular because education might
not equip some of them with the
capability to to perform at a high level
in a knowledge-driven global economy
hey